[Musique]
et Francis spinner vous êtes donc avec
nous pendant cette première demi-heure
vous avez on l'a compris été
nouvellement élu sénateurs de Paris vous
allez siéger dans le groupe les
républicains 130 suspense on va
évidemment revenir sur vos attentes sur
vos ambitions maintenant que vous faites
votre entrée au Sénat mais d'abord
l'actualité on l'a vu dans le journal
c'était manuel Macron qui a présenté
hier sa feuille de route de la
transition écologique et veut une
écologie compétitive juste souveraine il
a notamment annoncé 700 millions pour
bâtir 13 RER métropolitains il veut
aussi un objectif d'un million de pompes
à chaleur par an d'ici 2027 est-ce que
c'est une feuille de route que vous
soutenez le problème c'est que nous
avons en France
une écologie qui a été confisquée par
les groupes d'extrême gauche et donc que
l'écologie redevienne le la chose de
tous les Français de tous les partis
m'apparaît très sain et donc une
écologie qui n'est pas déformée par
l'idéologie de la décroissance de ce que
disent les Verts c'est intéressant donc
c'est une écologie de mesure l'écologie
ne peut pas être punitive l'écologie ne
peut pas être toujours dans les
interdits l'écologie elle doit être
positive certaines mesures du président
de la règle annoncée par le président de
la République m'apparaissent
effectivement bonne maintenant
le problème c'est que ça nécessitera
beaucoup d'argent et beaucoup de
convictions de tous les acteurs locaux
c'est-à-dire que l'écologie elle
commence dans la commune jusqu'au sommet
de l'État et que je ne suis pas sûr que
les mesures d'en haut
produisent des résultats dans ce qu'on
appelle le déteste ça l'expression les
territoires mais je pense que la France
doit continuer sa décentralisation
consacrée à l'écologie non il y a pas
assez d'argent mais il y a pas assez
d'argent dans la mesure où encore une
fois bien sûr que l'idée des transports
des RER dans les métropoles c'est une
bonne idée mais l'écologie elle commence
par le bâti du quotidien dans la plus
petite commune elle commence dont il a
parlé mais je le dis encore une fois
l'écologie doit être l'affaire de tous
et
à tous les niveaux et à tous les
échelons de responsabilité un mot sur
une mesure annoncée dimanche elle
concerne le prix des carburants Emmanuel
Macron qui dit qu'il y aura une aide
ciblée un chèque pour les Français qui
en ont réellement besoin de leur voiture
est-ce que c'est la bonne méthode c'est
le retour du chèque ecoutez le quoi
qu'il en coûte nous coûte très cher la
France est un pays endetté donc il y a
un problème de pouvoir d'achat c'est un
vrai problème dans notre pays et comment
le résoudre
du pouvoir d'achat et à l'intérieur de
ce problème du pouvoir d'achat il y a le
problème du prix de l'essence et là
aussi c'est pas en tant que sénateur de
Paris qu'on est le plus touché mais les
gens qui ont besoin de leur voiture pour
travailler avec des distances et ou
l'essence est un poids important dans le
budget c'est évidemment une grande
difficulté alors à partir de là où c'est
le chèque ou c'est effectivement
les taxes c'est un vrai débat
c'est la bonne solution moi je pense que
le chèque c'est pas la bonne solution
parce que d'abord pourquoi lui pourquoi
à moi dans quelle catégorie dans quel
seuil c'est une mesure c'est une Russie
mais je crois que le problème est
beaucoup plus grave beaucoup plus
compliqué trop le problème c'est qu'il
faut arriver à la fois à une rigueur
budgétaire la France ne peut pas
continuer à vivre au-dessus de ses
moyens et donc à partir de ce moment-là
comment l'État fait des choix et des
priorités
et non des aides qui toucheraient tout
le monde il faut tenir compte de la
rigueur budgétique
il nous explique qu'il faut tenir compte
de la rigueur budgétaire en creusant le
trou donc voilà
on va parler du Niger c'est un sujet que
vous connaissez bien Emmanuel Macron qui
entre autres annonce dimanche soir
annoncé le départ de l'ambassadeur et
des soldats français du Niger d'ici la
fin de l'année c'était inéluctable
c'était une Dabo je connais
malheureusement un peu le Niger j'avais
été en son temps l'avocat de la famille
du président Ibrahima Nassara qui avait
été assassiné par sa garde c'est dire
que la tradition du coup d'État au Niger
est ancienne à partir du moment où un
gouvernement pucciste
renverse un gouvernement légal que la
France est soutenue et soutiennent le
président mazoun qui est
démocratiquement élu démocratiquement
élu c'est pas une élection comme on
envoie dans certains pays qui est faussé
malheureusement
[Musique]
la réelle politique c'est qu'il y a une
jante au pouvoir cette jointe décide
de demander l'expulsion des soldats
français tout en touchant pas d'ailleurs
à la base américaine le groupe Wagner
n'est pas encore
ce sont des amis
on peut pas rester maintenant ça pose le
problème plus globalement de la présence
française en Afrique sur le plan
militaire dans nos anciennes colonies
nous avons des relations qui se sont
dégradées
pour le digère et l'exemple mais c'est
au Mali c'est aussi au Burkina Faso
ce serait très long de refaire
l'histoire des relations
franco-africaines
la France a échoué au Sahel mais
les régimes aussi ont échoué au sel
quand au Mali nous avons sauvé l'État
malien nous avons empêché cette
dislocation nous avons empêché la prise
du pouvoir par les djihadistes au Mali
est-ce qu'il fallait rester est-ce qu'il
fallait rester en appui on a donné le
sentiment d'être une troupe d'occupation
on aurait dû garder des éléments pour
pouvoir faire des interventions mais ne
pas avoir une force permanente qui
donnait l'impression de devenir entre
guillemets une force d'occupation dans
un pays en plus toujours compliqué entre
les Touaregs etc bon mais aujourd'hui
c'est un échec de notre politique
africaine qui ne remonte pas d'ailleurs
au mandat d'Emmanuel Macron c'est une
longue dégradation et je pense que le
point structure ça a été d'abord la
chute du régime libyen qui a déstructuré
complètement le Sahel fait circuler des
armes partout et encourager finalement
les groupements djihadistes bon il
faudra reprendre le dialogue avec ces
pays-là je pense que d'ailleurs la
mesure que vous les prendre je ne sais
plus quel ministre de suspendre les
visas sur le plan culturel était une
imbécilité la seule chose qui nous reste
qui va nous rattacher à ces pays
d'Afrique c'est la culture et la langue
et les élites africaines restent encore
attachées à la langue française à la
littérature française qui les
enrichissent qu'il contribuent
d'ailleurs parfois
à visifier et donc si en plus nous
perdons ce lien culturel il ne restera
plus rien
on va parler de votre arrivée au Sénat
Francis piner on va parler de vos
attentes de vos ambitions mais d'abord
notre journaliste Mathias arez va venir
nous dresser votre portrait
[Musique]
bonjour Mathias
du barreau absolument bientôt 50 ans que
vous portez la robe Francis spinner
Patrick Poivre d'Arvor l'empereur
Bocasse à Bernard Tapie Jacques Chirac
ou plus récemment le président du
Paris-Saint-Germain Nasser votre nom est
associé aux affaires les plus
médiatiques et médiatisés de ces
dernières décennies pourtant l'affaire
dont on vous parle le plus c'est celle
des emplois fictifs de la mairie de
Paris qui a notamment valu un an d'inel
éligibilité à Alain Juppé on regarde
tu as la Juppé ne fera pas de courroie
entre la en cassation
[Musique]
et que pour le reste il réservera au
bord de l'Est ses déclarations sur ce
qu'il entend faire et sur le la décision
qu'il vient d'être rentrée voilà merci
pourquoi avoir fait des affaires
politiques et économiques votre
spécialité Francis piner
mais c'est celle dont on parle le plus
vous voyez j'ai eu très peur quand vous
avez dit la fuir qui vous a rendu le
plus célèbre parce que figurez-vous que
souvent lorsqu'on parle on dit vous avez
été l'avocat de Madame Claude qui a
marqué ce qui a marqué davantage les
gens donc évidemment dans une maison
comme le Sénat vous vous braquez sur les
affaires politiques mais en réalité
d'autres vous diraient que
la croisade que j'ai mené le plus depuis
1983 ce sont les affaires de terrorisme
j'ai l'honneur d'être l'avocat de latifa
ibiatène dans l'affaire Mira mais
surtout pendant des années avec
Françoise rudetski qui était une femme
exceptionnelle pour SOS Attentats et
je pourrais dire que c'est l'histoire du
terrorisme qui défile depuis les Libyens
les Iraniens accent direct les
djihadistes donc on se braque dans une
maison comme le Sénat je comprends que
ça intéresse plus les affaires
politiques ou financières mais aussi
beaucoup d'affaires de droit commun
alors votre profil n'est pas sans
rappeler celui d'autres illustres
avocats avec un pied en politique et un
autre dans les palais de justice comme
l'actuel garde des sceaux Eric
Dupont-Moretti comment est-ce que vous
expliquez ces accointances entre ces
deux sphères alors j'aurais pu
totalement la comparaison parce que Eric
Dupont-Moretti
n'est pas élu
[Applaudissements]
oui mais
si vous voulez la différence est
importante je pense que la vie politique
c'est aussi un parcours une expérience
moi j'ai été ravi je suis ravi d'être
mère je regrette que simplement les
verres d'arrondissement n'est pas le
vrai pouvoir comme n'importe quel maire
mais d'abord c'est la légitimité du
suffrage universel et c'est aussi c'est
l'expérience j'avais été avant directeur
de cabinet il y a très longtemps du
président Alexandre Leon Thierry en
Polynésie je pense que c'est aussi un
métier bon maintenant quand vous êtes
avocat vous êtes toujours confronté à la
loi et donc il y a des moments où vous
dites quand même la loi elle est mal
faite si on pouvait être temps en temps
avoir des gens qui savent un peu
améliorer là où là où la rédaction donc
c'est sûr qu'il y a toujours la
tentation pour à juriste un avocat de se
mêler de la chose publique c'était une
tradition d'ailleurs sous la Troisième
République et la Troisième République ne
se portait pas si mal sous la Cinquième
les avocats sont moins engagés en
politique il y a beaucoup plus des
marques je ne dirais pas de mal de cette
nomme l'institution parce que je pense
que nous avons une fonction publique de
qualité la fonction publique et le
pouvoir politique c'est autre chose
alors justement il y a Francis piner
l'avocat il y a Francis piner le
politique Mathias il est difficile de
les dissocier Oriane puisque je le
disais Francis spinner s'inscrit au
barreau de Paris en 1975 et sa première
campagne électorale date de 1978 vous
représentiez alors les Radicaux de
Gauche à l'occasion d'une législative
par une législative partielle vous avez
également
occupé des postes politiques vous l'avez
évoqué comme directeur de cabinet de
président de la Polynésie française la
suite c'est un destin malheureux à
plusieurs élections législatives
notamment puis finalement en 2020 votre
premier mandat arrive et pas des
moindres puisque vous êtes élu maire du
16e arrondissement de Paris on ne l'a
pas dit mais vous êtes un vrai parisien
s'il en fallait c'était un mandat qui
vous parlait qui vous intéressait celui
d'être mère je suis habitants et donc
quand Jacques Chirac m'a dit pour des
tas de raisons qu'il fallait être
candidats sont des lois contre un mur
Montebourg je ne me suis pas dérobé
quand par la suite j'ai dû être candidat
en catastrophe pour remplacer quelqu'un
qui avait décidé au dernier moment de
changer de circonscription je l'ai fait
mais je suis parisien dans la main je
suis né à Paris j'ai fait toutes mes
études à Paris
à part ma parenthèse politicienne qui
n'est pas la pire chose qui puisse
arriver à quelqu'un et évidemment j'aime
ma ville et donc l'idée d'être engagé
pour sa ville
m'apparait surtout quand on voit l'état
de la ville aujourd'hui nécessaire et
donc j'ai été ravi d'être candidat dans
un arrondissement difficile parce que
comme la droite gagne tout le temps ça
suscite toujours des appétits et donc il
y a toujours beaucoup de dissidents nous
étions trois listes une menée par une
sénatrice l'autre menée par la mère
sortante donc c'était pas forcément la
facilité alors depuis dimanche soir vous
êtes un parlementaire élu en attendant
d'investiture
Amanda national que vous avez ardemment
désiré quel sénateurs serez-vous Francis
spinner
parce que je crois d'abord au travail
je le dis souvent aux étudiants
il n'y a que dans le dictionnaire que le
succès arrive avant le travail donc je
pense qu'au Sénat on travaille j'ai
toujours eu l'occasion lorsque je
m'intéresse à certains textes de loi
d'examiner les travaux parlementaires et
souvent j'ai trouvé les travaux
parlementaires du Sénat étaient de
meilleure qualité je pense que le Sénat
aussi un avantage il y a moins de
pression
il y a moins l'effet médiatique de la
petite phrase
du jeu politique on retrouve avec sa
superficialité
et plus de fond voilà donc j'espère être
un sénateur laborieux sur quelle
thématique aimeriez-vous travailler vous
investir
a priori je souhaiterais aller à la
commission des lois
et je suis évidemment les thématiques de
la justice du terrorisme de la sécurité
nécessairement donc de l'immigration
mais aussi sur un aller un sujet qui je
crois sera un sujet important pour notre
pays et pour
la condition humaine c'est
éventuellement une loi sur la fin de vie
et je pense que en l'état le projet
j'attends de voir ce qu'il sera parce
que ça peut être une rupture de
civilisation c'est-à-dire pour vous il
faut pas aller plus loin que la loi
actuelle ou avancer
une bonne loi quand j'observe ce qui se
passe dans les pays étrangers qui ont
fait sauter ce verrou et bien j'observe
que finalement nous allons à une dérive
et que si vous commencez à entre ouvrir
la porte en disant bon pour ça oui vous
arriverez à tous les abus ça c'est le
suicide assisté il faut pas aller il
faut pas aller dans cette voie le rôle
de l'État n'est pas de donner aux gens
les moyens de mourir
le rôle des soignants n'est des membres
d'ailleurs à ceux qui si je suis la
brebis galeuse de ma classe j'étais dans
une classe scientifique ils sont tous
médecins je suis le seul qui est mal
tourné qui fait droit bon
quand vous avez décidé d'être médecin
pour soigner vous avez pas idée d'être
médecin pour tuer et donc
cette idée de dire on va défendre le
droit de mourir dans la dignité personne
n'est pour le droit de mourir dans
l'indignité dans la souffrance mais
c'est une manière de dire les choses
c'est quelle est notre rapport avec la
vie quelle est notre rapport avec la
mort quel est notre rapport avec les
plus faibles
c'est un vrai débat et
je crois que ça c'est la noblesse de la
politique c'est qu'à un moment donné on
n'est plus dans les petits calculs on
n'est plus dans les affaires partisanes
on est dans une certaine conception de
ce qu'est la vie à la civilisation et je
pense que c'est un débat passionnant oui
votre engagement en politique c'est
aussi l'histoire d'une amitié avec
Jacques Chirac dont vous avez été le
conseiller qu'est-ce que qu'est-ce que
vous lui devez Jacques Chirac ou plutôt
qu'est-ce que je garderai dans votre
manière de faire de la boîte
j'appartiens à une famille
gaulliste avec une certaine idée de la
France et donc c'est naturellement au
RPR que je suis allé
ça serait trop long de vous expliquer
pourquoi les radicaux de gauche mais non
quand même alors mes parents avaient
avaient deux héros le premier évidemment
c'était le général de Gaulle qui avait
sonné l'honneur de la France et le
second c'était Pierre Mendès France et
quand j'avais 20 ans général de Gaulle
était mort et Pierre Mendès France était
vivant et Pierre Mendès France et tout a
dit quoi de gauche donc par affection
par piété filiale je suis allure
radicaux de gauche j'ai découvert
évidemment
que Pierre Mendès France y exerçait une
influence très faible que c'était
l'union de la gauche donc je n'y suis
pas resté je pense même que j'ai dû en
être exclu et donc je suis allé au RP
parce que comme disait Philippe Séguin
je sais pas si c'est un mouvement
gaulliste mais c'est encore là qui en
est le plus voilà et donc j'ai eu
l'occasion de rencontrer Jacques Chirac
j'ai toujours été frappé par son
humanité par son empathie et surtout par
son immense culture et sa compréhension
du monde et ce que je trouvais
exceptionnel chez Jacques Chirac c'est
qu'il était toujours en renouvellement
de des idées
je me rappelle un jour je devrais pas
dire ça d'ailleurs mais j'étais dans son
bureau et à ce moment-là il y a son
Sherpa qui vient Boris gourde montagne
qui dit monsieur le Président je viens
vous saluer parce que je vais apporter à
l'être
et je lui dis bah c'est pas drôle d'être
le sherpa du président toutes les jours
parce que se taper les altermondialistes
alors à l'époque j'avais pas encore
Sandrine Rousseau il y avait un certain
niveau mais c'était quand même un peu
bouillonnant et là Jacques Chirac me dit
vous avez tort mon cher Maître parce que
bien sûr
sur la France qu'elle disait inquiétant
mais ils disent des choses que nous ne
voyons pas et donc on a besoin toujours
d'écouter ce que disent ce dont nous
partageons pas les convictions dont nous
n'avons pas la même histoire mais qui
apporte quelque chose et c'est lui qui a
dit la maison brûle et nous regardons
ailleurs donc j'ai toujours été frappé
par cette capacité
à se renouveler à s'intéresser au
mouvement au-delà de ces certitudes
finalement je dirais Jacques Chirac
savait penser contre lui-même et c'est
en politique je crois une grande qualité
d'être assez libre notamment dans votre
vote et ensuite
une demi satisfaction c'est que mon
bureau à la mairie du 16e et le bureau
cocu qui avait Jacques Chirac quand il
était maire de Paris que Anne Hidalgo a
eu l'élégance de me laisser alors
justement on va parler dan Hidalgo
puisqu'elle a réagi dimanche soir
de 8 sénateurs de cochons rappellent à
Paris il y a 12 sénateurs qui ont été
élu 4 de droite 3 survêts seven
dissidente et oui sénateurs sur les
listes du nom de la gauche Anne Hidalgo
elle met ce succès de la gauche sur le
compte de la cite du spectacle terrible
souvent clounesque souvent dégradant
donné par Rachida Dati qui n'a pas donné
envie aux grands électeurs de voter pour
votre liste est-ce que vous lui répondez
que c'est très c'est une réponse très
Hidalgo c'est-à-dire faire fi de la
réalité pour raconter une histoire alors
on va on va dire ce qui se passe les
grands électeurs à Paris sont le
résultat des élections municipales nous
n'avons pas gagné les élections
municipales donc le rapport de force il
est connu mais madame Hidalgo je lui dis
aujourd'hui la première force politique
au Sénat de Paris ce sont les
républicains nous nous avons quatre
sénateurs elle elle en a trois et demi
est-ce qu'il y a une liste d'union de la
gauche et que donc ils se sont répartis
les sièges en fonction des forces
politiques à gauche le PS les
écologistes et les communistes et les
poires mais vos professeurs de
mathématiques vous disent que ça
marchait pas moi si je regarde les
résultats les communistes ont un siège
les écologistes en ont trois les
socialistes en ont trois plus un
quatrième qui apparenté au groupe
socialiste et nous nous en avons quatre
donc la première force politique au
Sénat qui a envoyé au Sénat à Paris des
élus CE c'est les républicains donc
venir dire et vous êtes quatre à gauche
ils sont vite à gauche et vous êtes 4
coalition qui ne s'entend pas et qui ne
s'y réunit que pour se partager les
places mais madame Hidalgo qui font
farod n'a pas plus de sénateurs que les
républicains donc c'est le résultat des
municipales et ils avaient excusez-moi
dans l'assemblée sortante ils avaient 7
sénateurs plus 1 parce que monsieur
barjoton était l'adjoint socialiste de
Madame Hidalgo il avait été élu par une
partie de la majorité socialiste qui
avait quitté madame Hidalgo pour aller
en marche et les socialistes n'ont fait
que la gauche n'a fait que récupérer son
siège donc en réalité nous avons un
rapport de force qui est strictement le
même qu'avant si ce n'est qu'avant
c'est pour ça que Madame Hidalgo de voit
doit se revenir au principe de réalité
avant nous avions quatre sénateurs sur
trois listes et qui siégeait
différemment aujourd'hui au groupe LR ou
groupe changer Paris nous sommes les
seuls à voir 4 sénateurs présents dans
l'hémicycle et trois ça n'est jamais
arrivé pendant 20 ans d'avoir sur la
liste officielle 3 sénateur l'ancien
prédécesseur dont j'ai oublié le nom qui
menait la liste il y a 6 ans la liste
officielle avait fait qu'un siège le
sien
on va continuer à parler d'Anne Hidalgo
merci Mathias à tout à l'heure
évidemment on parle Daniel Go avec
Jacques Pâquier qu'on retrouve tout de
suite bonjour Jacques directeur de la
rédaction du journal du Grand Paris et
Jacques vous allez nous parler de la
hausse de la taxe d'habitation à Paris
je voulais connaître le le
positionnement de maître spinner sur
cette question qui a été relancé bon
d'une part parce que les contribuables
parisiens sont en train de la payer et
d'autre part parce que le Président de
la République lui-même a créé une
certaine émotion dans les collectivités
en rappelant que c'était la
responsabilité des collectivités locales
vous le savez Francis spinner
l'argumentation d'un Hidalgo j'aurais
voulu savoir que vous en pensez c'est de
dire que finalement c'est la faute de
l'État si elle elle doit augmenter à ce
point-là la taxe foncière parce que
l'État ne rembourse pas certaines
dépenses liées au covid parce que l'État
refuse systématiquement les idées de
cette nouvelle que la mairie a à formulé
je pense à l'augmentation de la taxe de
séjour à la création d'une taxe sur les
logements vacants ou sur les résidences
secondaires elle dit aussi parce que
vous faisiez référence mettre à la à la
conviction Jacques Chirac sur le climat
elle dit aussi un Hidalgo comme vous le
savez
que ne pas augmenter la taxe foncière
c'est se condamner à l'inaction
climatique qu'en pensez-vous alors
attendez
la question globale c'est les finances
de la ville et d'abord c'est le train de
vie de la ville
je constate que la ville a beaucoup de
une masse salariale très importante pour
un taux de satisfaction très inversement
proportionnel pour les Parisiens alors
après il y a des il y a des questions il
y a des causes qui sont effectivement
normal la baisse des transactions
immobilières va entraîner une baisse des
recettes madame Hidalgo n'y est pour
rien mais en réalité
le budget la question du budget de la
Ville de Paris et de sa sincérité se
pose avec la question des loyers
capitalisés et donc depuis des années
nous sommes en réalité dans une dérive
budgétaire qui est masquée par cet
artifice auquel il faudra mettre fin
donc dire que c'est toujours la faute de
l'État sur le covid certainement que
l'État aurait pu faire plus moi je me
rappelle que dans ma mairie on m'a
demandé de faire deux centres de
vaccination j'ai pas vu
mais bien sûr bien sûr c'est elle qui
gère la ville c'est elle qui engage les
dépenses c'est elle qui a une politique
de suite cette augmentation de la taxe
foncière selon vous ah bah compte tenu
des finances de la ville je pense que
[Musique]
elle doit trouver de l'argent alors elle
aurait pu soit
vendre une partie du patrimoine mais
c'est le contraire par exemple je vois
dans mon arrondissement
lorsqu'il y a des logements libres elle
exerce un droit de préemption
et on paye très cher on paye très cher
ce qu'elle achète pour faire des
logements sociaux dont d'ailleurs la
question est à qui il profite bon donc
c'est toujours la même politique chez
Madame Hidalgo c'est jamais de sa faute
voilà alors que l'Etat lui fait quand
même des cadeaux lorsque on met à la
disposition un certain nombre de biens
appartenant à l'État qui sont vendus pas
toujours à la valeur ce qui est une
forme de subvention d'église à la ville
là elle ne se plaint pas de dire que
elle a pas acheté au prix du marché non
il faudra toute façon faire un véritable
outil des finances de la ville et
examiner de près mais déjà il faut
mettre fin à l'artifice comptable des
loyers capitalisés et ça c'est quelque
chose qu'il faudra faire après quand
effectivement moi je ne suis pas opposé
à une augmentation éventuellement de la
taxe de séjour mais c'est pas ça qui va
remettre à plat les finances publiques
mais là vous souhaitez ça demande
je pense que ça s'étudie parce
qu'attention c'est sûr que moi dans mon
arrondissement j'ai quelques palaces une
augmentation de la note dans le palace
de la taxe de séjour au prix de certains
des chambres ça passera inaperçu et
c'est pas un problème il faut voir aussi
c'est la même chose si vous mettez ça
dans un petit hôtel deux étoiles à la
demande pour les grands hôtels oui non
mais à partir de quand vous êtes
classifié comment etc merci Francis
piner on remercie Jacques paquet merci
Jacques d'avoir été avec nous la une
journal du Grand Paris et bien revisite
la place de l'architecte merci Francis
piner d'être venu nous voir quelques
heures après votre élection on espère
que vous reviendrez nous voir
régulièrement dans cette émission merci
beaucoup d'avoir été notre invité